secret professionnel qui est pas
respecté à la sécurité sociale
j'accouche on le met des règles on le
met direct sur Twitter le nom de mes
enfants etc alors je l'ai même pas
encore annoncé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que le vous avez un très gros
niveau et c'est un peu The Voice au
château et c'est ce que j'ai dit aux
élèves hier soir je leur ai dit parce
que je cache rien je leur dis moi je
suis embêté parce que c'est The Voice au
château et pour moi la Star Academy
c'est une école c'est le collège
Sainte-Marie de Tarbes là c'est la
Sorbonne si vous êtes tous hyper fort
vous savez danser chanter je trouve que
tu as un talon et c'est un peu le défaut
je voulais remettre juste un peu les
panneaux à l'air parce que samedi tu as
fait tes people donc ton émission la
seule et
et donc tu as dit que je critiquais la
Star Ac ce qui est absolument faux parce
que j'ai toujours dit que la star acte
fallait qu'elle revienne et j'ai dit la
seule chose que j'ai dit c'est que la
Star Ac comme je l'ai dit là ce sont des
élèves de The Voice qui dorment au
château donc pour moi les codes ne sont
pas respectés voilà et j'ai souhaité
longue et longue vie à Sarah avec de
bonnes audiences tu as dit ça donc tu
peux les remettre les trucs mais pas les
passer les tweets mais montre-les et
ensuite a dit que je ne pouvais pas
venir que tu m'avais invité que je
pouvais pas venir si tu étais un bon
animateur tu discuterais que ta
production j'ai ma maman qui est très
malade et je vais être devait être près
de ma mère voilà et donc ça m'a un peu
emmerder parce que
ça va mettre un trou du cul donc quand
on sait pas on ferme sa gueule
c'est comme ça moi je suis franc du
colis au lieu de dire
tout le monde te dira que j'ai déjà tout
le monde
c'est nul c'est mauvais on s'ennuie un
live ça manque de gens Pascal bien sûr
je le recruté
tout le monde te le dira on l'a dit
non
jamais
le faire parce que peut-être comme du
pain à faire un tour dimanche
il avait dit non non je vais y aller
mollo
[Musique]
sur snapchat et plus de 538 sur insta
voilà plus les personnes me suivaient
plus le harcèlement s'empirer ça a
vraiment commencé le vrai harcèlement je
pars du harcèlement dangereux à la
naissance de ma fille c'est Anna donc
c'est mon rôle de mère qui a directement
été pointé parce que voilà être maman à
19 ans etc enfin c'est comment
aujourd'hui mais une maman qui expose ça
tout etc on va vite la juger on va tout
remettre sur l'âge etc et c'est à ce
moment là que vraiment le harcèlement il
a été intense
votre téléphone c'est votre travail
exactement du coup oui plein d'autres
choses des péripéties qui peuvent
arriver à plein de gens comme des
cambriolages des choses comme ça en fait
à chaque fois qu'il m'arrive quelque
chose le film ça veut dire que je vais
acheter du pain je vais le filmer je
vais marcher je vais dire que je marche
enfin voilà quoi c'est naturel quoi
déjà je pense la chose qui a été le plus
dur dans mon harcèlement ça a été le
fait qu'on me ramène les assistantes
sociales chez moi pour remettre en cause
l'éducation de ma fille que j'aime et
que j'embrasse j'aime plus que tout
c'est sympa ok ils vous ont dit à
travers quoi à travers les vidéos que
vous montez voilà et exactement ils ont
pris des vidéos hors contexte par
exemple une vidéo où je suis dans la
piscine je filme ma fille elle est
également dans la piscine mais il y a
personne autour du cadre de ma fille
elle embrassa etc et elle dit que il y a
personne dans la piscine pour surveiller
la petite mais moi je l'affine la fin la
petite donc je suis dans la piscine
aussi cambriolage aussi qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
en fait j'étais au Maldives avec avec
mon mari et vous étiez aux Maldives en
fait ils sont montés chez moi j'habite
j'habitais dans un immeuble au quatrième
étage et ils sont fait passer pour EDF
aller vraiment prévenir les voisins qui
auraient des travaux ils ont cassé la
porte et voilà et c'est ouais c'est la
vidéo qu'on voit ici
plus de cambrioler la maison ma mère
elle vient de m'appeler ils ont cassé la
porte et tout c'est rien mon bébé tu
m'as pas vu ça y est tu as eu peur et
puis ils ont laissé ça sur le lit c'est
pour ça qu'elle allait avoir l'argent
regarde l'état de la porte
et c'est rigolo alors il y a plein de
gens qui se disent aussi c'est peut-être
je viens te faire cambrioler tu vas me
mettre ça sur les sur les réseaux c'est
le réflexe que tu as tout de suite je
contrôle pas trop mes émotions moi je
suis parfois je regrette ce que je mets
je vais jamais dire que j'ai jamais rien
regretté malheureusement tout ce que je
dis aujourd'hui ça prend tellement des
proportions que même si je regrette au
bout de 5 minutes ça y est c'est déjà
partout en fait donc il y a plein de
choses ça je le regrette pas c'était mes
émotions ça m'a fait du bien de partager
ça j'ai eu des témoignages de personnes
qui se sont fait cambrioler etc un
cambriolage c'est pas à prendre à la
légère c'est un traumatisme c'est un
c'est excusez-moi du terme mais c'est
comme un viol en cambriolage on est
rentré chez vous on a vu où vous dormez
on a vu où vous l'avez etc donc ouais
aujourd'hui je m'empêche de partager
plein d'autres choses que j'aimerais
directement dire etc mais en fait elle
met tellement des bâtons dans les roues
sur plein de choses que par exemple je
vais aller au resto elles vont annuler
ma réservation du resto si je vais dire
les filles je vais manger un restaurant
on voit la Tour Eiffel elles vont savoir
enfin elles vont taper les restos de
Tour Eiffel elles appellent l'autre fois
j'ai été avec mon mari et elles avaient
annulé la réservation je suis arrivée je
me suis plantée il y avait pas de
réservation ton mari il en a pas marre
que tu sois tout le temps sur ton tel
et on peut plus
comment tu peux ça comment tu peux
montrer ton enfant comme ça à
l'intelligent sans son accord c'est à
dire que peut-être peut-être que plus
tard cette fille-là va avoir des
problèmes sans son accord alors en fait
déjà ça je vais pas dire ça a été malgré
moi parce que ça a été un choix mais
c'est un à chaque fois que je sortais
dans la rue on essaie de me voler des
photos c'était un vivable je la cachais
je la mettais sous-découvertures etc ça
c'est le premier point dans tous les cas
elle aurait fuité comme mon fils a fuité
je marchais à l'aéroport il y a pas
longtemps on apprend en photo mon fils à
mon insu on l'a publié
vraiment tu la mets comme ça
ma fille absolument pas non pas du tout
elle est très aimée elle est enfin voilà
ça a été une continuité pour moi elles
m'ont vu marier elles m'ont vu mettre au
monde cet enfant et la montrer en fait
ça a été un peu malgré moi mais il y a
mon choix il a été influencé par ma
communauté oui je voulais leur montrer
ma fille aujourd'hui
tu peux plus revenir en arrière c'est où
tu te dis stop et en fait j'arrête tout
et je vais aller travailler un travail
je vais aller trouver un travail je sais
pas un autre travail normal j'ai envie
de dire entre guillemets ou bien je suis
obligé
harcèlement en fait moi hashtag il a
tellement pris tes proportions que je
comprends pas les milliers de mails que
j'ai envoyé à Twitter qui disait rien
fait pour ça on croirait que ça les
amuse de voir la publicité sur un
hashtag qui prône le harcèlement toute
la journée
enfin je sais pas c'est pas un tweet
c'est pas deux c'est tous les jours
depuis deux ans et demi c'est vraiment
un pesant c'est faut le vivre pour le
comprendre et peu importe ce qu'il y a
derrière dans tout le cas personne ne
mérite d'être harcelé d'être moindre
fait chez elle et alors toi tu le joues
aussi parce que tu tomes tu montres ta
vie donc voilà c'est en fait c'est le
oui comme je disais tout à l'heure au
niveau des critiques et tout ça c'est
totalement normal tu prends ce cet
aspect des réseaux sociaux tu prends
aussi les critiques et tout ce qu'il y a
derrière mais mettre en danger les
enfants etc ça c'est quelque chose que
il y a même pas que ça il y a les
secrets professionnels qui est pas
respecté à la sécurité sociale
j'accouche on le met des règles on le
met direct sur Twitter le nom de mes
enfants etc alors je l'ai même pas
encore annoncé ce que tu es heureuse
aujourd'hui
oui mais oui mais pas ouf je pourrais
l'être encore plus qu'est-ce qui ferait
que tu sois encore plus on me laisse
tranquille en fait tu m'aimes pas tu me
suis pas et puis voilà j'ai même pas
tout simplement pas qui
souhaitent faire du mal faire du mal
vraiment elles font elles font des gros
problèmes elles envoient des messages à
mon mari et elle vont très loin elles
vont très loin très très loin ça dissout
les liens familiaux etc c'est c'est
au-delà des réseaux sociaux là
apparemment Neymar facturer une
apparition en boîte de nuit 20
000 euros 20000 euros donc il arrive il
fait
c'est peut-être quelqu'un de son
entourage et dit il vient et peut-être
qu'il a essayé de prendre un billet ah
c'est ça je pense ça il va pas nous dire
la saison je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus et moi aussi ouais
je vais te donner des chroniqueurs
vraiment tu vas nous dire combien il
sait sérieux il va nous dire vraiment
combien il vous paierez pour aller faire
une apparition
combien tu donnerais pour Castaldi je
vais le dire c'est quand même il est
quand même grande gueule mythique 3000
euros
[Applaudissements]
je pense tu reçois un coup de fil demain
Valérie
mon contrat après avec Adidas t'inquiète
pas
[Applaudissements]
combien alors Gilles Verdez s'il y a le
problème c'est qu'il y a deux prix il y
a le prix pour son cachet et le prix
pour la sécu qui va l'accompagner
c'est ça donc 2000 euros parce qu'il y a
moins 1000 euros de sécu avec le plus
c'est ça que les gens c'est un
personnage
une question et surtout les lèvres où se
trouve Justine verac dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche la jeune femme de 20
ans disparait sans donner de nouvelles
après une sortie en boîte de nuit le
samedi à dimanche Justine sort en boîte
une boîte qui s'appelle la charrette à
Brive-la-Gaillarde elle habite à une
quarantaine de kilomètres de là elle y
va en voiture mais elle est elle est en
bande avec ses amis
vingt ans un moment vers 3h 4h du matin
elle demande à sortir enfin elle veut
sortir prendre l'air éventuellement même
aller dormir dans sa voiture et il a un
de ses copains qui l'accompagnent jusque
là j'ai envie de vous dire tout va bien
et alors qu'ils arrivent aux extérieurs
c'est-à-dire le copain est Justine un
individu celui qui est en garde à vue
actuellement va
décider de s'occuper de Justine en
disant aux copains rentre retourne à la
soirée je gère on se connaît
effectivement il se connaisse de vue
pour cette croisée plusieurs fois dans
la boîte de nuit et à partir de là plus
de son puis d'image on a plus de
nouvelles de Justine le dimanche pas de
nouvelles du coup forcément les parents
s'inquiète alertent les services de de
la gendarmerie et très vite on pense
cette affaire au sérieux et le fameux
Lucas va être
interpellé c'est un ouvrier agricole il
a 21 ans lorsque les gendarmes arrivent
chez lui pour l'interpeller il trouve
pas mieux que de prendre la fuite à la
vue des gendarmes nous sommes avec
Alexis et Maxime bonjour deux proches
de l'homme qui a voulu le meurtre Lucas
là il a avoué en garde à vue la
dernièrement Lucas c'était c'était il y
a quelques heures alors une garde à vue
de manière très très généraliste c'est
une mesure de contrainte qui s'impose à
quelqu'un qui est soupçonné d'un crime
ou un délit et pour lequel l'enquêteur a
besoin de le garder à sa disposition
comment comment vous connaissez Lucas
c'est pour ma part c'est familialement
que je le connais d'accord depuis que je
suis assez jeune vous connaissez depuis
longtemps depuis que j'ai deux ans que
j'ai des que j'ai déménagé en Corrèze et
vous aussi moi je le connais depuis
moins longtemps mais on s'est rapproché
c'est vachement rapproché et tout on n'a
jamais eu tant de problèmes que ça c'est
un gars qui était bosseur il voulait que
ça réussir j'ai cette année il a il a eu
tous ces trucs il a passé ses super
lourd il a eu il a eu son bébé il a tout
eu
il a eu un bracelet certes on sait pas
comment c'est fini l'histoire
de Justine
je sais pas si c'était j'ai pensé à lui
tout de suite quand vous avez vu la
photo du signe ouais j'ai pensé à lui
tout de suite c'est faut savoir que ils
étaient pas des inconnus
on a déjà fait des soirées ensemble
d'accord il se connaissent ils se
connaissait déjà parlé sur instant
il y a eu fricotage c'était pas des
inconnus
meurtre cadavres
quand vous avez entendu ça de quelqu'un
que vous connaissez
toujours que ça arrive qu'aux autres
vous êtes dit quoi il est devenu fou ou
il a toujours été fou c'est une durite
il a du boulot
c'est une explicable c'est une
explicable et vous étiez avec nous au
départ au départ de soirée oui au départ
de soirée oui il avait bu
on avait on avait vu un peu on avait bu
on était pas c'est un samedi soir
et vous disiez quoi lors de la soirée il
était normal rien à dire tout le monde
se retrouvait on se pose au bar et
voilà après moi je l'ai laissé quand il
est parti à charrette moi du coup je
suis rentré si j'étais fatigué que donc
il a avoué avoir tué la jeune femme
Justine chez lui
après il y a une variation hype
d'aujourd'hui un rapport sexuel consenti
et la police dit viol et lui dire
rapport sexuel consenti il l'aurait tué
d'un coup de poing il aurait tué d'un
coup de poing alors que des traces
d'armes contondantes ont été retrouvées
mais il dit l'avoir tué d'un coup de
poing et l'avoir enterré à l'aide d'un
engin agricole en lisière d'un bois
comme ça plus avoir effacé les traces
c'est ce que ça nous comment vous
réagissez
vous savez on est 1300 habitants dans ce
village ça tourne très très vite c'est
une personne qui est facile une famille
quand même assez connue
très respectable très très respectable
et enfin
c'est un village en deuil franchement
enfin on sait pas quoi dire on sait pas
quoi penser je vais vous parler du signe
parfois ou pas du tout
oh non on en a parlé une ou deux fois
quand on la voyait quoi
si tu le voyais bien en boîte il dansait
ensemble
c'est même les médias qui m'ont appris
qu'elle avait un copain
d'accord et quand il est
si vous l'aviez vu pour avoir il est
déjà parti avec elle voilà au cours de
soirée elle s'est elle est Justine elle
est elle s'est dit bon voilà je risque
rien avec lui
[Musique]
jeudi dernier dans la nuit un adolescent
entre dans le domicile d'une famille
aurait agressé sexuellement une petite
fille de 6 ans dans sa chambre et des de
ses amis le père de famille absent au
moment des faits va alors tenter de le
retrouver par tous les moyens j'ai pété
un câble je suis devenu fou je voyais
qu'une chose c'était l'attraper après
des rondes de surveillance il finissent
par tomber sur l'agresseur présumée et
avant de le livrer à la police le père
de la petite fille décide de se faire
justice lui-même j'ai réussi à le
rattraper et je l'ai roué de coup pour
revenir sur cette affaire qui fait
énormément agir on va recevoir une
personne qui est au cœur de l'histoire
il s'agit de boules à noir un voisin de
la famille qui a participé à rechercher
le jeune homme coupable d'agression
sexuelle même chez vous vous attendez en
sécurité total
c'est chaud en fait
vous êtes dit je vais essayer de
retrouver vous êtes tout seul quand vous
le cherchez moi de mon côté ouais je
suis tout seul tout seul depuis 23h30 je
tournais je suis allé à 2h30 2h 2h30 je
suis plus exactement
voilà je me gare je me pose c'est pas
c'est quoi ou quinzaine de minutes et 24
heures après à 20 minutes près des temps
plein de récit de quoi sur la même
maison mais bien sûr il est en train de
regrouper le grillage sur la même pour
aller dans la même maison oui dans la
même maison de là où il est parti la
veille de là où personne l'attrapé je
suis allé vers lui je suis resté une
dizaine de minutes en face à face avec
lui dans le noir total vous lui avez
parlé ouais j'essaie de le questionner
j'essaie de comprendre qu'est-ce qui
faisait là moi je fais quoi entre-temps
j'ai envoyé un message à mon pote je lui
dis ça
tranquille prends une photo
on va voir ta femme c'est chaud mais va
voir ta femme vois ce qu'il en est mon
pote il part il amène la photo à sa
femme le problème c'est quand il est
revenu au lieu de garder son sang-froid
tout pépère et tout arrive à 4,5 mètres
de lui il m'a dit c'est lui
donc là il est arrivé il a collé c'est
lui quoi il a dit c'est lui le mec il
est parti comme un V12 c'est bon pas
c'est que la quête elles ont volé en
l'air après il y a un pote à moi il est
sorti
voilà on a réussi à le canaliser après
voilà il était dans une rage folle que
il faisait que tourner pour essayer de
le faire c'est logique c'est logique
bref ou la noire la police arrive au
bout de combien de temps vous pouvez
nous dire au moins ça vingtaine de
minutes 15 minutes
donc on va essayer de minutes les plus
longues de votre vie c'est compliqué
franchement c'est comme ça franchement
franchement ça vient pas penser qu'un
jour je voudrais ça un truc de barjot
donc en gros moi et mon pote il veut
laisser de me coller un soi-disant
violence en réunion c'est ce que j'en
passe c'est ce qu'on lit exactement pas
de problème donc maintenant je vais vous
dire autre chose
ça peut encourir jusqu'à 50 prisons pour
un père qui défend sa famille
et un mec qui soit disant à 16 ans il a
pas 16 ans le mec bien sûr que dans ce
papier là saison sinon il va finir où
rétention contre le jus du ciel
pardon contrôle de centre de rétention
plutôt
moins de 16 ans il va pas être envoyé
vous en voulez à qui aujourd'hui je sais
pas qui en vouloir vous voulez en
vouloir écrire en fait
c'est ça le problème parce qu'en fait
moi je suis pas dans un délire d'en
vouloir bien sûr de pas en vouloir j'ai
pas le temps pour ces conneries
[Musique]
de s'installer dans la cave d'un
immeuble parisien près de la Tour Eiffel
elle fait 500 euros par mois qu'elle
paye en cash pour vivre dans un 9 m² une
situation qui ne devait être que
temporaire la dernière fois il y a eu 40
cm d'eau partout la moitié de mes
vêtements étaient fichu mais pour le
tribunal Matilda qui n'a aucun bail à
présenter doit être expulsif pire la
justice lui demande de payer 12000 euros
aux propriétaires pour occupation
abusive de son logement
ici je m'en vais mais après ça s'arrange
pas ça s'arrange pas ça s'arrange pas ma
vie ne s'est pas améliorée
avoir un une toit et c'est mieux de que
dormir dehors et sur un pont
à l'époque j'ai gagné 1800 euros donc
500 euros pour lui voilà et le reste
pour moi vous avez toujours payé votre
loyer en liquide
et
lui il me prenait 50 euros tout le mois
pour pour le leader
le tribunal va malheureusement se
prononcer contre vous c'est fou vous
n'avez pas de bail à présenter pour eux
il s'agit d'une occupation abusive et
vous êtes condamné à payer 12000 euros
au propriétaire
aujourd'hui vous avez un logement social
mais n'est aucun n'est pas d'argent pour
n'évoque un meuble
voilà on va nous envoyer grâce à
l'enseigne au carré rouge spécialiste de
l'ameublement et de l'électroménager
canapé lit appareil électroménager télé
cet ancienne nous accompagne sur
nombreux projets solidaires vous le
savez merci à eux et on va bosser sur
votre dossier pour vous aider aussi pour
voir sur les 12000 € ce qu'on peut faire
l'avocat mais en tout cas on va vous
meublé l'appartement vous avez eu
je peux rien te dire je peux rien faire
pour toi la seule chose que je peux
demander c'est Dieu de te bénir que ton
émission enrichisse
merci ma chérie donc c'est réglé voilà
je te fais un gros bisou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]